You set me on fire. You do
n't have to do anything to help me. Leave the manual labor to the
female hands and leave me
alone. [Music] But you're also dying, so there
's no problem. More than that, this amount is abnormal.  Well, it's
certainly possible that even legal undead were lured into the area, but that's
why I'm asking you to monitor the legal undead to make sure they don't do any strange things.For that reason, I'd like to make
sure they know their whereabouts and have a means of communication in advance.
That's
why I think they all came from the same place.
Undead can't teleport. In
other words, if they were hiding all over the city, there's
no way that many of them would arrive at the same time unless they transcended space.  Well, it's hard to
imagine that they were in the city without knowing this number in the first place.The distance was
less than 40 minutes by human foot from the time the lantern was turned on.I purposely
chose a place that was out of the way to avoid danger, but apparently I couldn't measure it.
Looks like you've hit the nail on the head.
[Music]
Hey, what's the point of being a data magician? He keeps telling me, "You're so
tired, you're so cool! You
better be careful with beautiful women. I'm getting laid too, my
wife."  Don't worry about your butt, yo
JA